- Garder son calme, mais se
tenir prêt. C'est un peu ce que
Maxime et sa copine Rachel
chchchoisi de faire. Après tout,
dit Maxime, la guerre avec
la Russie a commencé
depuis longtemps déjà. " " " "Lé
il y a huit ans, dit-il.
Alors on s'est habitué."
La guerre est en cours depuis
l'occupation de la Crimée.
Mais ces derniers temps,
ils ont fait de l'ordre dans
leurs documents, ont fait
épépépéparer un passeport
pour le chat et en cas d'attaque
russe à Kiev, le jeune couple
n'emportera que le strict
miniu'u'u'u'ils ont déjà
bien rangé dans
des sacs à disposition.
"L'idée, c'est de prendre
trè c c c c choses, dit-il.
Si quelque chose de grave
arrive, comme des bombardements,
je n'ai qu'à prendre mon sac,
y mettre mon ordinateur
et me mettre à l'abri."
C'est une angoisse sourde
et résignée, mais surtout
un refus de céder à la panique
et de laisser les tensions
des manoeuvres militaires
aux frontières du pays asphyxier
le quou'u'u'u'u'on sent bien
à Kiev.
"Bien sûr, je m'inquiète, dit
cette femme. J'ai des enfants,
des garçons qui sont en âge
d'être appelés à se battre.
Mais ce n'est pas comme
si j'y pensais sans arrêt.
La vie continue, il y a autre
chose dont on doit s'occuper."
Ce banquier à la retraite
a moins peur des bombes
et des armes que des dommages
bien réels que la Russie
pourrait infliger à l'Ukraine
sans même que le sol
ne soit foulé par
les bottes de ses soldats.
"Je m'inquiète plus
des mesures économiques que
la Russie pourrait prendre,
comme un blocus de l'énergie,
des ressources comme le gaz
et l'électricité du Bélarus,
dit-il. Ça pourrait vraiment
jouer sur notre situation
économique. Mais je vois
les troupes russes aux
frontières comme un pistolet
sur notre tempe."
Si les manoeuvres militaires
se poursuivent de part
et d'autre et avec elles,
les accusations de provocation,
les efforts diplomatiques
n'en demeurent pas moins
intenses. Dans toutes
les grandes capitales,
les coups de fil,
les visioconférences
se poursuivent. Les visites
ici à Kiev de dirigeants aussi.
C'était au tour du président
de la Turquie Erdogan
aujourd'hui de rencontrer
le président Zelensky
pour offrir ses services
de médiateur. Les Ukrainiens ici
à Kiev se disent très
reconnaissants du soutien de
la communauté internationale,
même si certains craignent
que l'Ukraine ne finisse
par payer un prix trop élevé
pour une situation diplomatique.
La plus grande crainte
de ce chien de garde
de la démocratie et
de la transparence dans
la politique ukrainienne, c'est
que les efforts diplomatiques
forcent l'Ukraine à céder
aux demandes de la Russie,
quelles qu'elles soient.
"Les Ukrainiens ne sauraient
l'accepter", prévient-t-il.
"Déstabiliser la société
ukrainienne et miner
la confiance que nous avons
envers le gouvernement,
c'est précisément ce que cherche
l'agresseur russe aujourd'hui.
Ils vont se servir de ça comme
d'une excuse pour que
leurs troupes envahissent et
se présentent comme
des Casques bleus
venus faire la paix."
La meilleure défense
des Ukrainiens, croit-il,
est donc de rester unis
et solidaires. La Russie,
elle, restera toujours une épée
de Damoclès au-dessus
de l'Ukraine.
Ici Marie-Eve Bédard,
Radio-Canada, Kie